こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです。
ただいまモーリーファンタジー清水店さんに
来ております
えっとお
最近ですね、こちら
まえですねえ、はじめしゃしょーのパペットが
UFOキャッチャーであったと思うんですけども。
今回新しくこちらはじめはじめしゃしょーの
指人形が5種類と、
はじめしゃちょー目覚まし時計が2種類、新しく出ましたー。
ダメめっちゃガン見されてるんすよ　今
人目がやばいな、人目が。
はい、
で今日なんですけども
皆さん、どれくらい取れるか分からないと
思うんですよ。
前回、パペットのときもー
今回ボクが身をもって、
これ全部100円玉です。
で、今からこの100円玉100枚、10000円使って、
これで皆さんは何円かければ大体取れるかな、
ていうのが分かると思うので、
参考にしてくれればいいなと思っております。
では行こう。
はい、じゃあ獲っていこうおもいます。
一応 配分としては指人形のほうで5000円
目覚まし時計のほうで
5000円使っていこうと思います
とりあえず、5000円で全部獲れればいいなとおもいます。
100円目いきます
200円目いきます
200円でさすがに1個は取りたいところである
キタっしょ
これむずくない？
300円目いきます
400円目いきます
ほぼ 横になってるから あとはこう何か
掴み上げればいけそうな気がする
500円目いきます
ちょっと思ったより難易度高めですね
ほぼ 横になってるから あとはこう何か
掴み上げればいけそうな気がする
600円目いきます
これはきたっ！
700円目いきます
いいんじゃない？
ダブルダブル！！
あ～～ちゅーしちゃったぁｗw
800円いきます
どうだ
900円目いきまーす
あ～！！顔がっ…
惜しいんだけどなぁ
今さ、EDいけそうじゃない？
EDの頭狙いでいきます
10回目いきます！千円分
まだゼロはヤバいぞほんとに
これはきたこれはきた！
あ～いいよいいよいいよ！きてるよ！
も～惜しくない？
1100円目いきます
待って、どうすればいいの？
12回目
お！お！お！お！お！お！お！
はい、というわけで1200円でやっと一個取れました
口がEDになってるやつ
1200円でやっと一個取れたんですけど
このままちょっと一気にやっていこうと思います
1300円いきます
よし！２個目です ２です個目
1400円いきます
うまい！うまいうまいうまい…
1500円いきます
よし！２個目です ２です個目
3000円までに全種類 確保したい
2300円目いきます
2800円目で黒髪取れました
残りは あとひとり
2900円目いきます
よし　OK!OK!OK!
まあ　いい結果じゃない？
完璧でしょ
ええ　でもいいんじゃない？
2300円目いきます
残りは あとひとり
時計の方に行きます
400円残して無事はじめしゃちょーの（目覚まし）時計も取れました
ちょっとココにきて難かしくなってたきね
ただ多分これですごい時間かかったんで
本当はそんなに かかんない予定だったんで
いよいよ（100円が）少なくなってきました
（倍速中）
よっしゃー！！↑↑（3回）
[エンディング] まだあるよ～　最後までみてね～～
400円残して無事はじめしゃちょーの（目覚まし）時計も取れました出来ました
ぼくの場合、総額
ただ多分これですごい時間かかったんで
本当はそんなかかんない予定だったんで
残り400円残ってるんで
残り400円でもうちょっと
指人形とか取っていければいいなと思ってます
なるべく取ります！！